sono tornato sigla
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bella tutti ragazzi oddio
siamo partiti di merda bella tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono pari j
oggi siamo anzi oggi iniziamo una nuova
serie nuova tra virgolette perché
l'avevo già iniziata ma non così siamo
sul surge simulator 2013 ma sul
videogame originale questa versione
ufficiale che vi stavate richiedendo da
secoli
diciamo contiene molto più di una una
sola un solo intervento chirurgico ma ce
ne sono mi pare ben tre quindi rega
preparatevi perché sarà una serie
fantastica voleva soltanto scusarmi se
in questi tre giorni la canon o
pubblicato nulla ma veramente ragal con
la scuola ci stanno svago nando di
compiti e quindi veramente difficile
purtroppo rega per il mese di maggio
sarà un po così perché
è il mese in cui si dobbiamo dare più
dentro diciamo noi comuni mortali
studenti e io ovviamente sono studente
di notte è chirurgo di giorno e quindi
direi che possiamo iniziare con le
operazioni purtroppo a maggio
se ogni tanto lo metto video cercate di
capirmi perché è così detto questo raga
direi di far uscire il nostro braccio
bionico
ci siamo allora è domani dovrebbero
essere gli stessi vediamo se riesco a
ricordarmi come cazzo si fa allora
aspettate un attimo mi ci va un secondo
se oggi ci siamo è più o meno si allora
c'è qualcuno ok mi stanno chiamando al
telefono gianni un attimo canio seconda
chi siamo
chissà cazzo non si stacca ok pronto
[ __ ] non ordinato nessuna pizza devo
lavorare state zitte of a kay evitatele
disturbarmi lavoro dagli orologio
maledizione hanno fatto perdere loro
agio
ok raga iniziava un malissimo se n'è
andato il mio rolex che cazzo
va bene dalla direi a qualche buttare
giù tutto sulla scrivania cosa dobbiamo
fare qui cosa devo fare allora ci sono
operazioni
sfido raga ci sono anche le sfide perché
ci sono le pillole cazzo queste proprio
a dottor house cioè si impasticca ok
direi di andare su operazioni ma ci
siamo allora trapianto di cuore la
galera il trapianto è quello che abbiamo
già fatto è ovviamente quello che avete
già visto
ok eseguì un trapianto di cuore perfetto
ci siamo alla rara ga ce la stiamo per
fare
siamo tornati su sanchez u simulator
allora il trapianto di cuore lo sapete
tutti perché è la variante hanno già
fatto un paio di volte però questo è
diverso perché ci sono strumenti nuovi e
quindi non è come ripetere quello
normale allora innanzitutto noto che con
piacere che hanno elevato la cazzo di
radio e hanno messo la sveglia per il
paziente credo alla labili a sto cazzo
di roba davanti prima di tutto
soffochiamo il paziente si soffoca
raga possiamo prenderlo a schiaffi ma
che cazzo svegliati stronza ok dobbiamo
eseguire un trapianto di cuore perfetto
allora l'ho fatto miliardo di volte più
basse ecco allora ho bisogno
innanzitutto del martello raga il
martello per rimuovere la parte
superficiale del nostro paziente con
molta moltissima calma bisogna ok
perfetto ci siamo guardate con che
delicatezza vai col cazzo
perfetto allora vediamo innanzitutto i
polmoni che come sapete tutti se avete
seguito la mia famose elezioni polmoni
non servono a un cazzo se si toglie
maledizione devo togliere le ossa in
superficie che cazzo si sta togliendo
poi chissà
maledizione i polmoni inutili che cazzo
lo hanno fatto a fare perché essere
umano sia i polmoni maledizione osserva
non sa se conserva una maledizione
perché non si fa anche le ossa che cazzo
l'hanno fatta fare
sapete che cosa servono le ossa la mia
teoria la teoria di famiglia che servono
a rompere il cazzo i dottori quando
operano perché non servono a nulla via
via tutto cial pane perfetto allora
ragazzi stiamo arrivando al vostro
obiettivo il cuore allora hanno aggiunto
degli organi che prima non c'erano
certo di gomma che collega ambedue le
parti del nostro stomaco che non è
comunemente chiamato esofago ma tubo di
gomma allora dobbiamo innanzitutto
rimuoverlo o cazzo microfono a mio
avviso no bellissimo ragazzi ci hanno
messo gli attrezzi giusti altro cedeno
coste saggio simula lock up perché
perfetto lo impugnato malissimo
dovete ricordare che bisogna sempre
impugnare alla perfezione quindi
saldamente i nostri strumenti e opera o
cazzo e operare come si deve allora
bisogna tagliare quell'affare lì allora
se si taglia male disabili no è partito
un po maledizione polmoni di merda che
non servì fa un cazzo
sempre in mezzo alla mischia
allora i polmoni adesso micheli bandisco
nella mia sala operatoria
paranormal trapano ufficialmente
bandisco i polmoni
nella mia sala operatoria è vietato
fumare sono vietati cani e sono vietati
i polmoni che non servono un cazzo
proprio un cazzo di niente allora sta
roba qui una volta impegnato a saldare
da cazzo aiuto
ok si era impiantato il trapano ma
niente di che state tranquilli bisogna
ok e k
il trapano non funziona è guasto o
bisogno richard a quell'ora è ragazzi
nel caso o il vostro paziente stia
perdendo sangue
provate a fare a far circolare nelle
vene un qualcosa di liquido tipo una
fanta magari a che cosa serve ai ragazzi
il paziente sta morendo la dedizione
dobbiamo salvarlo svegliate svegliati
stanza svegliati zaia che cattivi
maledetto ok è bene non era esattamente
che ufficio doveva andare va bene allora
ragazzi ricordatevi sempre che la prima
operazione soltanto di allenamento è
sempre così perché non si può mai
eseguire un'operazione alla prima la
prima volta perché si vuole diciamo è un
po per scaldarsi ecco per per farla
breve quindi la prima operazione è
sempre così sul chi va là applica altro
per riuscire a riprendere confidenza con
gli strumenti giusti è la seconda
operazione quella che contavano
innanzitutto spegniamo il monitor qui
prima abbiamo iniziato in modo molto
lento e sbagliato ma ovviamente scusate
mi da un po che non esercita la mia
professione pluripremiata di chirurgo
all'inizio si usa il trapano se si
accende maledetto stronzo accendi te che
cazzo è bello o che è perfetto il
trapano andato via che ci siamo bisogna
o cazzo
bisogna impugnarlo correttamente
ovviamente stavano parte il trapano
una volta impugnato il trapano
rimuoviamo le ossa inutile mi sembravi
offrendo un film horror cazzo
e va bene sì bisogna rimuovere le ossa
che non servono gli eteri stronz
che cazzo perfetto allora via al trapano
raga è una cosa indecente
direi che il buon martello è l'unica
cosa che non si può mai sostituire
perché perdono orologio che cazzo perché
vabbè pazienza il trapano deve fare il
suo lavoro alle ossa come se stessi
apprendendo un quadro se poi allora
direi che ci siamo ragazzi abbiamo
soltanto ex club stato ok dove primo
fallito adesso non fallirò a circa più o
meno trenta secondi per eseguire
l'operazione prima che il paziente
voglia dissanguato ma ce la farò allora
vediamo innanzitutto sta roba che non
serve assolutamente a nulla meno dei
polmoni
se riesco che cazzo è ok perfetto va ci
siamo allora tutto il tutto appoggiato
delicatamente sul tavolo non diamoci
allora laga una cosa molto delicata
togliamo tutto quanto ci dovremmo quasi
essere cazzo il ferro i vostri 980 mila
litri di sangue e merda
bisogna riuscire offre perfetto ci siamo
molliamo ci muoviamo c'è che capitali
che deve servire lavorazione più veloce
del mondo allora bisogna tagliare quella
roba è un qualcosa di sottile alla
veloce però che perfetto sottile si
chiama togliti roba inutile nova per
chiedere per i [ __ ]
ok tagliate quell'affare tagliatelo
prima che no visto impigliato nel cuore
che cazzo
togliti brutto stop ma perché è ok
paranormal seghetto ragazzi stiamo
riuscendo praticamente è un seghetto
automatico si taglia da solo è
fantastico da perfetto raga è bene e
anche la seconda è andato a [ __ ] o
cioè ragazzi siamo ci siamo
definitivamente
ricordatevi soltanto una cosa nel caso
perché mi ha finito la ragione del
paziente va bene non fa niente tanto non
lo sta notando nulla finché non se ne
accorge va bene
ricordatevi soltanto una cosa raga nel
caso vi capita di essere operati da me
in futuro
assicuratevi di passare come terzo
paziente della giornata ok mai come
primi due ci dovremmo essere se non
riesco a ucciderlo prima devo manca
l'osso qui ce la facciamo ciò che cazzo
mi sento thor costò martello se fra
cassia monitoraggi alla gente
ebbene allora togliamo sta merda
fantastico ci siamo ragazza volta ce la
facciamo come lo sento sono tranquillo
occhiali dov'è la dottoressa che mi
permettesse la spugna sulla fronte che
gli serve sto sudando per riuscirci ma
allora togliamo stan togliti togliti
maledetto straccia
ci siamo il primo andato e ragga manca
secondo e dopo stiamo per i mental punto
eravamo fermati prima però con fango e
siamo a buon punto ha dato mise
incastrato il dito nell'esofago ma che
cazzo togliti ci siamo se ce l'abbiamo
fatta ma anche soltanto che devo
decidere il mega tubo di gomma
all'interno del paziente con una penna
possibilmente no con la penna meglio di
no direi di utilizzare un qualcosa di
leggero stavolta veramente se non
mandiamo a [ __ ] tutto per l'ennesima
volta allora ce la possiamo fare
e difficile da prendere perché sulle
dita più grosse di un elefante anche se
gli elefanti non hanno le dita ce la
possiamo fare
impugnato saldamente sì ci siamo e
dobbiamo ok se non fatta sia tolto
ragazzi è tolto ce la faccia allora
togliamo sta roba tirano come se stessi
facendo il tiro alla corda
dobbiamo decidere i tubicini di gomma
del cuore ce la faremo
prenditi ma che cazzo allora ce la
facciamo
l'operazione delicata ma ce la si può
fare ma mai capito se opera come se non
ci fosse un domani e di sicuro per il
paziente non ci sarà un domani ma vabbè
l'abbiamo ce l'ha fatta
cazzo mi rimasto ovvio le rimasto a chi
se ne frega tanto cuore da togliere gli
si è conficcato tutto ci siamo ragazzi
il quale c'è il cuore c'è chi guarda
brutta stronzate l'ho tolto guarda è
bene allora lo mettiamo qui perché
ovviamente paziente affezionato i propri
organi e ci si può dormire insieme voi
dormite coi peluche i pazienti dormano
che i propri organi ce la possiamo fare
allora ragazzi ci serve il nuovo cuore
taiuti scatola inutile ce la facciamo
allora il cuore c'è bisogna solo
appoggiarlo delicatamente all'interno e
posizionarlo nel modo corretto in modo
che il paziente possa vivere a maggio
visto store come faccia incollarla a
qualcuna dell'attak in sala operatoria
malizia abbiamo vinto cielo ma d'orlando
a saltara rimasto niente legami stava
morendo di nuovo ma ce l'abbiamo fatta a
cinque minuti di operazione ragazzi come
diploma ce l'abbiamo fatta
è incredibile sono fiero di me stesso ho
finito la prima operazione la prossima
operazione un trapianto di reni e
l'ultimo come potete leggere il
trapianto del cervello
sarà fantastico volevo soltanto farvi
notare una cosa praticamente di ogni
operazione è possibile seguire la stessa
in ambulanza quindi la che potremo fare
il trapianto di cuore
il trapianto di reni e il trapianto di
cervello anche in ambulanza e sarà
veramente fantastico quindi l'avremo per
tipo cinque o sei puntate tutte credo
direi che possiamo finirla qui
smettetela di chiamarmi stronzi non ci
sono per nessuno adesso vado a guardare
la puntata di scrubs dopo questo brutti
stronzi me lo merito
quindi non chiamatemi prima di mandare a
[ __ ] da scrivania
direi di finirla qui se avete dei
suggerimenti comunque da fare dato che
come gioco la pena iniziato se avete
delle cose divertenti dà da fare è
suggerita mela e comunque io nel
prossimo episodio android trapianto di
reni e preparatevi per il trapianto di
cervello e soprattutto per l'operazione
in ambulanza che sono fantastiche dottor
fa vj per oggi si prende una pausa
ok dio mio che cazzo sta roba mi soffoca
ogni volta
vabbè sei lì dove è piaciuto lasciato il
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo in
un prossimo video bella ragazzi